foreign
Justin's in Tampa Florida hi Justin how
are you
hey how you doing Dave better than I
deserve how can I help
so my question is me and my wife have
been doing our finances and I've come to
notice that she has a credit card
spending issue and I thought maybe we
should get a smaller amount credit card
to help so that she can't spend so much
is this going to solve anything or is
this just a bad idea all around
um I I don't think she has a credit card
spending issue I think you have a
household Vision issue okay I can agree
the two of you don't have a big enough
vision for your future that you're
willing to uh pay the price to do and
instead we're acting like little
children and buying whatever we want
whenever we want it which is what most
Americans do and that's why most people
are broke
and so you need a bigger Vision I want
to change my family tree I want to be
able to travel I want to be able to
drive a car that's not a piece of crap
that I pay cash for I want to be able to
whatever I want to be able to be
outrageously generous to people
especially this time of year I'm
activated on to do all that and we're
too dead gum broke because our money
processes and our money habits suck and
so we need a bigger Vision that we're
both willing to give up our bad habits
to get to the bigger vision and then the
credit cards just go away
because they don't they don't they're
not included in a big vision of people
who want to win with money you just get
debit cards you don't need a credit card
gotcha saving put it away yeah just the
whole thing goes away I mean you need to
chop them all up and have an emergency
fund and have a budget and be working
your way out of debt and you sound like
you're fairly new to our stuff
yes sir okay yes sir all right I'll send
you a Christmas present you and your
wife look at it it's called The Total
Money Makeover and it walks you through
a detailed Proven Plan step by step on
what you can do to get control of your
money get you some money habits that
work but you're treating the symptom
you're not training the problem yeah and
he knew that I think he just needed to
hear someone else say it you know I'm
going to limit your undisciplined
as opposed to Let's remove the lack of
discipline yeah that's what we want to
attack but no one does discipline for
discipline's sake no gotta have a big
picture I don't want to lose weight
reasons right you know or whatever it is
for this yeah that's right